oui dans contrairement contrairement à
ce qui est écrit sur le tableau ma
question ne s'adresse pas à madame la
ministre de la santé
mais monsieur le premier ministre du
fait que la semaine dernière pendant
l'examen du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale en présence de
madame buzyn le président de la
république a annoncé que des réformes de
l'hôpital seraient annoncées par le
premier ministre lui-même
donc ma question s'adresse à lui
puisqu'elle porte sur l'hôpital monsieur
le premier ministre il n'ya dans ce que
vous avez présenté ce matin qui esquisse
la grande réforme dans l'hôpital besoin
absolument rien de convaincant il a les
attendait les professionnels de santé un
plan de sauvetage
ils n'ont eu que du rafistolage les
réalisations se sont transformés en
prime ponctuelle soumise à conditions
les 300 millions d'euros de plus pour
2020 sont maîtres sont à mettre en
perspective avec la 800 millions d'euros
de déficit annuel des hôpitaux et après
avoir contribué à en étaient les
hôpitaux faute de leur donner les moyens
de fonctionner vous vous contentez
d'alléger leurs dettes d'un tiers
monsieur prémunissent où nous avait
présenté le plan pour la santé 2022 il
ya 14 mois le plan pour les urgences il
y a 6 mois
manifestement ils n'ont pas atteint
leurs objectifs on peut d'ores et déjà
parier malheureusement qui en sera de
même pour vos dernières annonces
pourquoi monsieur le premier ministre
n'avez vous pas fait le choix d'une
réforme en profondeur de l'hôpital
[Applaudissements]